bonjour à tous les deux merci beaucoup
d'être ce matin en direct sur rt france
alors une question d'abord qui intéresse
les français évidemment pour commencer
alors que l'autriche confine à partir
d'aujourd'hui les non vaccinés les
candidats ont été interrogés hier sur
l'opportunité d'une telle mesure d'une
telle mesure seul le xavier bertrand et
valérie pécresse il serait favorable
regarder
s'il y a malheureusement une
recrudescence de la pandémie qui mettent
en danger des vies je ne confierais pas
tous les français j'envisagerai
uniquement leur confinement des non
vaccinés s'ils y à des décisions
difficiles à prendre je les prendrai à
l'égard des non vaccinés alors en cas de
fort regard épidémique faut-il confiner
les non vaccinés ou leur faire payer par
exemple les frais d'hospitalisation
comme à singapour françois cormier bulli
gens
n'ont pour l'instant nous ne sommes pas
vous avez vu que l'état a pris ses
responsabilités et a engagé un effort
important précisément pour vacciner
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens plus nos
concitoyens peut se faire dessiner il ya
le plus de 100 millions d'injections ca
les derniers mois et vous avez vu que
même si le tour remonte il est beaucoup
plus faible que chez nos voisins les
plus proches donc pour l'instant le
gardon ce qu'implique et un cap
équilibré avec le pass and i ter et la
vaccination qui est impossible par tous
les français il faut rappeler que ce
vaccin fonctionne et donc continuer à
inciter comme mon présent de république
à celle la semaine dernière inciter
leurs concitoyens qui ne l'ont pas
encore fait de se faire vacciner c'est
ça la ligne de conduite à avoir à ce
stade ouais là est la question de cette
fameuse troisième d'eau stéphane le
rudulier votre avis sur la question eric
ciotti est contre
oui je pense que lille a raison d'autant
plus que nous avons mis en oeuvre depuis
le mois de juillet dernier à passe
sanitaire qui a entraîné il faut le dire
une vaccination avec des taux de
couverture au niveau de la population
française assez important c'est taïg ça
a été une réussite ce que l'on peut
déplorer sur le suivi d'épidémies c'est
que l'exécutif a choisi de faire
cavalier seul sans pour autant consulter
le parlement dans les mois à venir par
rapport à l'évolution de l'épidémie
c'est très regrettable nous avons
toujours joué le jeu en temps
parlementaire et il est clair que ce
n'est pas à l'exécutif seul de décider
des mesures d'exception comme l'heureux
confinement je rappelle qu'on est dans
un régime d'exception jusqu'au mois de
juillet prochain c'est ce que a décidé
l'exécutif c'est déplorable parce qu'on
voit très bien que en fonction de
l'évolution de la situation les
parlementaires auraient eu leur mot à
dire sur d'éventuelles mesures de
restriction des libertés françois
cormier bullygeois vous n'êtes pas
d'accord on va avancer néanmoins parce
qu'on a beaucoup de questions notamment
par rapport au débat d'hier soir des
candidats qui ont été très offensif sur
la question de l'immigration en prônant
un droit du sol limitée eric ciotti lui
veut carrément rétablir le droit du sang
stéphane rue de lier
oui en fait c'est l'idée c'est qu'on ne
vienne plus français par hasard ces deux
effectivement ramener le droit du sol au
droit du sang tels qu'ils existaient
dans le code napoléonien pour éviter des
naturalisations ma cible ou en fait les
personnes n'ont pas véritablement en eux
l'amour de la france l'amour de leur
pays ça s'est vu lors des attentats
malheureux du 13 novembre 2015 dont on
va fêter le sixième anniversaire
avant-hier françois cormier un
bullygeois que pensez vous de cette
mesure on imagine qu emmanuel macron a
dû regarder avec attention ce deuxième
débat comme le premier d'ailleurs
l'émigration est ce que c'est son point
faible
non mais en tout cas on voit bien que la
droite dite républicaine a perdu sa
boussole c'est un peu aujourd'hui un
canard sans tête parce que en réalité
cette proposition de revenir au droit du
sang c'est tout simplement revenir à une
proposition de jean marie le pen des
années 80 et donc on voit bien que jade
est aujourd'hui divisée sait plus où
aller parce que une partie de son
programme
aujourd'hui appliquée par la majorité
présidentielle un rassembler derrière
emmanuel macron et que aujourd'hui ils
ont le choix entre eux servir leur pays
ou privilégier leur parti ceux qui
privilégient le pays ont déjà rejoint
emmanuel macron parce que nous mettons
en place toutes les mesures qui
permettent de protéger les français et
de protéger notre économie je
rappellerai que nous avons mis en place
une loi de programmation militaire la
plus ambitieuse de l'histoire de notre
pays avec un prêt 300 milliards d'euros
ni en âge nous seront recréés plus de
10000 postes de policiers et gendarmes
d'ici la fin du quinquennat avec l'an
prochain un budget record de l'intérieur
à 22 milliards d'euros
nous avons voté une loi protégeant les
principes républicains et j'ai bien
apprécié
une remarque d'une des personnes
interviewées d'ailleurs qui disait que
ce qui a fait démarrer hier lors du
débat entre les candidats élèves
sur un principe républicain et il avait
raison de le dire et puis nous avons mis
en place un train défense qu'on a appelé
le quoi qu'il en coûte qui a permis de
soutenir notre économie française
du président il l'a déjà fait mardi à
priori
aujourd'hui ceux qui privilégient le
pays ont déjà rejoint la majorité
présidentielle ou soutiennent le présent
d'un public et soultz qui nous veulent
uniquement que privilégier leur parti
les élèves sont dans une course sans fin
avec la droite extrême et les chats
noirs et c'est tout à fait agréable pour
eux stéphane hurel le rudulier
oui je vais je vais répondre parce que
si privilégier son pays c'est accepter
que 2 millions d'étrangers en cinq ans
sont venus s'installer sur le territoire
français j'appelle pas ça protéger les
français et protéger son pays encore une
fois à l'immigration a atteint des
records
tels que nous sommes obligés d'avoir des
mesures très forte en la matière alors
quand on parle d'immigration à monsieur
macron il vous propose un bilan un
catalogue de mesures qu'il a pu qu il a
plu en blanche enclenchée sur les cinq
années qui viennent ou sur l'immigration
n'est très clair on veut mettre en place
des quotas au plus strict minimum on
veut revenir sur le droit du sol et par
rapport au droit du sang on veut
également supprimer le regroupement
familial et l'aide médicale d'état c'est
la raison pour laquelle eric ciotti un
projet ambitieux mais rien ne point se
faire sans avoir traité ce problème
migratoire on est à la veille d'un choc
migratoire sans précédent au niveau de
l'europe ça se voit par rapport à ce qui
se passe en pologne à la frontière
biélorussie et c'est la raison pour
laquelle il faut traiter ce problème
avant toute chose je veux bien qu'on
fasse le bilan des manuels macron on va
pas se renvoyer la balle mais quand on
voit la dette publique explose et à 3000
milliards d'euros il n'y a pas de quoi
se réjouir du bilan d' emmanuel macron
mais en tout état de cause sur le sujet
de l'immigration c'est véritablement un
échec du quinquennat d'emmanuel macron
françois cormier voulez joindre à les y
réponde et brièvement et je vous montre
les noms mais je vous parlais de vous
parler de la dette publique par rapport
aux cas qui envoûte mais j'imagine que
vous avez quelques autres surgissent
dans votre camp nou dans vachon
département est donc allé interroger les
chefs d'entreprise ou à tout ce que
j'interviewe touche les voir tous ceux à
qui je rends visite dans le cher ou
ailleurs nous remercier des mesures
curité qui se passerait bien de sauver
les entreprises et les emplois c'est ça
la réalité et moi je regrette une chose
voyez on serine achats collègues
sénateurs mais moi je vois que vous
reprenez les idées les mots et des
statistiques de l'extrême droite si vous
êtes dans une rupture avec la droite
républicaine avec la tradition de droite
républicaine qui existe depuis général
de gaulle en passant par valéry giscard
d'estaing et jacques chirac vous êtes en
rupture totale
le droit du sang la théorie du grand
remplacement là volonté d'eric ciotti de
créer un guantanamo à la française c'est
à dire être en rupture avec l état de
droit aujourd'hui vous êtes en clair un
moment totalement décalé vous fait une
sortie de route et vous êtes sur les
terres du front national moi je le
regrette parce que les élus de droite
républicaine que je ne pouvais pas
attendre département dans la
circonscription ils n'ont absolument pas
ce même discours est donc aujourd'hui
vous êtes en train de vous en écarté
parce que vous avez un scrutin interne
dans quelques jours mais vous êtes en
train de perdre la raison je vous invite
à retrouver la raison et à retrouver le
sens de la république pour te réponse
alors je vous invite tout simplement
chers collègues à lire la convention du
rpr et l'udf de 1990 où les mesures que
les propos d'eric ciotti était déjà dans
le dans le programme du rpr et l'udf
signé par valéry giscard d'estaing et
jacques chirac ce que je sais il ne
faisait pas partie de l'extrême droite
en 1998 c'est un constat qui a été fait
depuis 30 ans ce constat il peut être
partagé mais en même temps les solutions
doivent être forte et ferme sur le sujet
de l'immigration
l'idée étant que si nous traitons pas ce
sujet nous tournons pas développer
l'ensemble des politiques publiques qui
doit mener la france au rétablissement
alors est ce que ça ne serait pas le
parti présidentiel qui est recherché les
les idées de la droite républicaine en
tout cas lors de son allocution aux
français mardi dernier au lendemain du
premier débat a l'air emmanuel macron
s'est clairement positionné à droite sur
le chômage sur le travail et sur le
nucléaire regarder les demandeurs
d'emploi qui ne font pas de recherche
active verront leurs allocations
suspendues c'est par le travail et par
plus de travail que nous pourrons
préserver notre modèle social
pour garantir l'indépendance énergétique
de la france nous allons pour la
première fois depuis des décennies
relancer la construction de réacteurs
nucléaires dans notre pays et continuer
de développer des énergies renouvelables
enfin françois cormier vous les gens
chacun va chercher les voix là où il
peut finalement
non je sens qu'on va surtout nous
chercher l'intérêt général de notre pays
et vous voyez vous et de valeurs de
droite enfin nos valeurs travail ou même
de nucléaire l'oralité ces valeurs-là
elle est de droite et de gauche
la position présidentielle quand
maintenant
sur le nucléaire donc pas du tout on
reste sur la trajectoire de rééquilibrer
le mix énergétique mais pour
rééquilibrer le mix énergétique dans la
mesure où nous avons des centrales
nucléaires qui sont vieillissants et
bien évidemment nous envisageons d'or
reconstruire parce que le nucléaire
c'est une énergie décarbonée a permis de
répondre à l'ambition écologique c'est
une énergie qui est stable et c'est une
énergie qu'il est peu cher et dont nous
voulons à la fois développer le
nucléaire et développer les énergies
arrive là sur la valeur travail qui a
pas une entreprise où je me rends dans
la circonscription du cher ou ailleurs
et qu'ils ne soient pas en recherche de
salariés et donc le fait de vouloir
permettre aux demandeurs d'emploi de
répondre aux propositions d'emploi qui
existent sur le marché sané avait ni de
droite ni de gauche et de droite et de
gauche et puis vivre de son travail
plutôt que la location c'est le minimum
de la dignité humaine pouvoir nourrir sa
famille à vivre sa famille passion
travail c'est moi ce que je pense que
c'est un minimum pour la dignité humaine
à partir du moment où la croissance
économique le permet moi je crois que
j'ai demandé en vain de joie en étant
formés sur les postes qui sont
disponibles doivent pouvoir les prendre
aux nazis et de droite et de gauche
c'est vraiment purement acronis c'est
d'ailleurs ce que nous proposons un des
puits 2016-2017 donc ya pas nos
changements par rapport à ça alors s'en
allait forcément évidemment sur une idée
de droite également la réforme de
l'assurance chômage stéphane le rudulier
que pensez vous des mesures qui ont été
annoncées par emmanuel macron confirmé
en tout cas par emmanuel macron 1 mardi
dernier la droite elle prône un
rapprochement du du brut
vis-à-vis du net du salaire brut qui se
rapprocherait du salaire net est ce que
la droite a une vraie différence la
droite républicaine avec ce que propose
le gouvernement
c'est à dire que la droite va beaucoup
plus loin sur des mesures de pouvoir
d'achat
effectivement l'idée par exemple de
rapprocher le brut le net du brut c'est
à dire par l'allègement des charges
sociales des salariés c'est quelque
chose que tous les candidats prônent il
ya aussi également sur la fiscalité
certains candidats comme eric ciotti
propose une flaque taxe c'est à dire un
impôt unique de 15% quels que soient les
revenus engendrés sauf pour les revenus
inférieurs au smic à 1200 euros on
propose également de supprimer en ligne
directe l'impôt sur les successions et
les donations c'est ce qu'on appelle la
peau sur la mort est également exonérées
jusqu'à cent cinquante mille euros les
donations entre grands-parents et
petits-enfants donc sur le peler les
mesures de pouvoir d'achat la droite va
beaucoup plus loin eric ciotti va va
beaucoup plus loin j'aimerais juste
revenir sur le nucléaire c'est quand
même assez
déboussolant de voir un président de la
république il y a quelques années nous
dit c'est la fin du nucléaire il faut
consacrer notre nos investissements sur
les énergies renouvelables et se rendre
compte que le nucléaire est garant notre
indépendance nationale et énergétiques
et le fait d'avoir fait des choix comme
la fermeture de fessenheim a affaibli
incontestablement
la place de la france par rapport à cela
et donc on peut saluer le revirement de
dernière minute et c'est là où on voit
bien que le précédent match on a les
yeux rivés sur le congrès certes mais je
pense que tous les ministres ont suivi
avec attention hier le deuxième débat
afin de reprendre les meilleures idées
de chaque candidat pour essayer de bâtir
un programme ça me rappelle étrangement
ce qu'a fait emmanuel macron en 2017 ou
on attend on m'a entendu le projet
rappelez-vous d' emmanuel macron à fin
février 2010 est c'est-à-dire deux mois
avant le premier tour ce qui veut bien
dire qu'il n'ya pas de se connaître
idéologique au niveau du maquereau nice
il picore d idées à gauche il picore
décidé à droite tout ça pour faire un
programme mais ça ne fait pas pour
autant un squelette idéologique hui
yable et qui pourrait sortir de la
france de l'ornière dentelle à
l'intérieur où elle français kambou
ligeron le gouvernement les fait peser
la la la prime la fameuse prime
d'inflation de 200 euros sur les
entreprises est ce qu'elles pourront la
verse et on descend de cette prime
vous savez les hanches frisottés quand
même beaucoup chuté ces derniers mois et
ils ont reconstitué de la trésorerie et
des marges de manoeuvre dont le jeu
n'est pas beaucoup d'inquiétude
l'assumer j'aurais revenir sur ce qui
s'est dit précédemment avril et candidat
à l'investiture des maires sont dans
l'incantation nous nous sommes dans
l'action un coco les sénateurs dit qu'il
faut beaucoup plus pour les pouvoirs
d'achat rennes et ils font rien pour
l'instant ils ne font que parler nous
depuis quatre ans et demi nous avons
redonné et milliards et des milliards
d'euros de pouvoir d'achat aux français
en baissant les impôts en défiscalisant
les heures supplémentaires en
revalorisant un certain nombre
d'allocations là très clairement il ya
eu une hausse importante du pouvoir
d'achat pour nos compatriotes et ça
c'est pas dans l'incantation c'est de la
réalité vécue à la fin de chaque mois et
des salariés les entreprises où je me
rends la défiscalisation des heures sup
ça c'est quelque chose qui leur parle
c'est du concret ça n'est pas de
l'incantation par contre c'est
intéressant ce que dit mon collègue sur
le fait de rapprocher le nen du brut
parce que les cotisations sociales
aujourd'hui elles servent à financer
l'assurance maladie l'assurance chômage
l'assurance retraite c'est à dire le
modèle social le modèle républicain
français donc ce qui est en train de
nous annoncer une par exemple un
candidat comme eric ciotti c'est tout
simplement la destruction du modèle
social français font ce qu'ils font dans
concitoyens on ait une conscience
aux jeunes de la présidentielle
les retraites voyez ce qu'on dit les
sénateurs qui ont voté en catimini en
tout cas ça pas fait beaucoup de bruit
là le prolongement de l'âge légal
écoutez ce qu'on a dit bruno retailleau
emmanuel macron est le seul président
depuis 30 ans à n'avoir rien fait tandis
que le sénat a pris très régulièrement
ses responsabilités
un commentaire stéphane le rudulier oui
pour m'inscrire totalement en faux avec
mon collègue de l'assemblée nationale
ces mesures sur le pouvoir d'achat
seront financées c'est pas la fin de
notre modèle social c'est simplement des
mesures de contre en contrepartie comme
la retraite à 65 ans et le retour aux 39
heures parce qu'il faut dire la vérité
aux français il va falloir travailler
plus pour pouvoir encore consolider
notre modèle social donc en aucun cas il
s'agit de rouergue visé est de réformer
notre notre modèle social simplement
donner du pouvoir d'achat par rapport à
des mesures où on va travailler plus on
sera plus productif ou un ca plus
compétitifs également à l'échelle
européen et à l'échelle mondiale alors
est ce que vraiment les différences
aujourd'hui françois cormier bullygeois
avec la droite républicaine pas celle
forcément pas les idées forcément
défendu par par le con d'éric ciotti
mais y at il des différences eric ciotti
se targue de ne pas avoir mis son
bulletin dans l'urne pour emmanuel
macron lors de la précédente élection
regardez
je suis le seul candidat au congrès à ne
pas avoir voté maquereau en 2017 pour
deux raisons son discours sur l'algérie
et son discours communautaire de
marseille non la france n'a pas commis
de crime contre l'humanité non la france
n'est pas un pays multiculturel alors à
vendre avant de vous faire agir stefano
le rudulier votre commentaire françois
cormier bullies on vous êtes confiant
sur le fait de faire monter le le score
4 25% pour l'instant de dans les
sondages pour emmanuel macron
non mais vous voyez ce discours
déplorant qu' il ya quelques années
justifiait selon lui de ne pas choisir
entre emmanuel macron et madame le pen
et qui lui fait aujourd'hui dit il qui
pourraient aller avec eric nous on voit
bien aujourd'hui ce que je disais tout à
l'heure au début de ce débat qu'il ya
une perte de repères cette partie de la
droite est totalement déboussolé et du
coup moi je comprends pourquoi beaucoup
de la droite ont rejoint le présent de
la république 1 dans son projet d'unité
nationale de l'actuel premier ministre
jean castex à l'ancien et d'un feeling
jusqu'aux ministres les plus importants
bruno le maire
roselyne bachelot jean michel blanquer
envoyer toutes ces grandes figures de la
droite préfère travailler au service de
la france tu ton que le bond des petites
ambitions partisanes parce que ces
petites ambitions partisanes elles ont
un dégât collatéral à porter haut ces
deux petites antilles glisser vers la
droite extrême
réagir également cette question de la
fidélité aux idées de droite et ne pas
prendre position pour emmanuel macron
notamment est ce que c'est ce qui va
compter dans cette primaire en tout cas
absolument je pense que la fidélité à sa
famille politique vous savez eric ciotti
est quelqu'un qui s'est engagé depuis 40
ans au sein du rpr je pense qu'il a il
n'a pas de leçon à recevoir de quiconque
sur ces valeurs qui sont des valeurs
issues du général du général de gaulle
là encore c'est un passionné macron
c'est pas parce qu emmanuel mâcon a
appris dans son gouvernement en trois ou
quatre personnalités de la droite que la
droite n'existe plus il ya qu'à voir que
les républicains sont le premier parti
de france en terme d'adhérents donc je
sais que ça déplaît à monsieur macro et
à la république en marche mais les
républicains ne sont à mort tout au
contraire on voit bien que à travers le
congrès à travers ces débats qui ont
lieu depuis depuis plusieurs semaines
maintenant et qui se poursuivront
jusqu'au 1er décembre les idées sont à
droite est en fête emmanuel mâcon vient
simplement picorer quelques idées pour
essayer de bâtir un projet présidentiel
c'est véritablement déplorables et est
véritablement encore une fois les
valeurs de droite ne sont pas les
valeurs d'extrême droite on nous associe
à eric zemmour c'est pas parce qu'on
partage
un constat avec monsieur zemmour quand
même temps on a les mêmes solutions la
preuve en est c'est que monsieur zemmour
a pris ce constat pour écrire des livres
pour faire vendre des bouquins alors que
eric ciotti par exemple appris ce
constat pour proposer des solutions
merci beaucoup c'était fallu reculer on
n'a plus le temps malheureusement on en
reparlera merci stéphanie rudulier et
merci à vous françois cormier bullygeois
d'être venu de débattre en direct ce
matin dans la matinale rt france